As one of the most popular franchises in all
of pop culture, fans spend a lot of time dissecting
each frame of a Star Wars film.
The saga is a touchstone for generations of
moviegoers, meaning that many people are well
versed in each of their secrets.
But even the most die-hard supporters can
get stumped every now and then.
There are aspects of the movies that have
yet to be revealed.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Star Wars mysteries
that were never answered.
Anakin’s Conception
In Episode I, it’s said that Anakin was
born without a father, and his mother Shmi
can’t explain what happened.
It’s a subject that’s not really touched
upon again until Revenge of the Sith, when
Chancellor Palpatine tells Anakin the story
of Darth Plageuis.
Sidious’ old master, Plageuis could manipulate
the midichlorians to create life, but the
film stops short of saying this is how Skywalker
was conceived.
It’s a reveal George Lucas had planned in
the original script, but he cut it – and
now the answer may never be known, making
one wonder why the miracle birth angle was
introduced in the first place.
Vader Doesn’t Sense Leia
Darth Vader is one of the most powerful Force
users in the galaxy, so why couldn’t he
sense his own daughter?
In Return of the Jedi, viewers learn that
Leia is Luke’s twin sister, and therefore
one of Vader’s children.
It retroactively creates a plot hole, since
Vader never felt something in the Force that
hinted at that.
During the Death Star trench run, he was very
aware that Luke was strong with the Force,
and Leia, while no Jedi, was still able to
use it.
Vader should have been able to sense the presence
of another Force sensitive being, especially
when he’s standing right in front of her.
Yoda’s Species
Every alien and creature that shows up in
the Star Wars films has a name.
Many of them, like Wookies, Ewoks, and Hutts,
go down in history and become memorable parts
of the zeitgeist.
But ask anyone what Yoda’s species is, and
there will be no reply.
The wise old Jedi master is just shown as
a small green alien with pointy ears, with
no mention of what kind he is being made.
Even when another of Yoda’s people, Yaddle,
was shown in the prequels, the answer was
never revealed.
It’s one that will puzzle Star Wars fans
forever, and is unlikely to ever be solved.
Luke’s Dagobah Training
In The Empire Strikes Back, Luke heads to
Dagobah to train with Yoda, while his friends
fly in the Millennium Falcon trying to avoid
the Imperials.
The way the film is edited, it seems like
Luke was with Yoda for just a few days learning
the ways of the Force, but that hardly seems
like enough time to become a Jedi Knight.
That’s a process that should take months,
but it’s hard to believe Han, Leia, and
Chewie spent that much time cooped up in the
Falcon evading their enemies.
Fans will just have to use their imagination
to come up with a proper answer, since this
topic won’t be covered again.
Maker of the Prophecy
When he discovers Anakin, Qui-Gon determines
that the boy is the Chosen One a Jedi prophecy
speaks of – one who will bring balance to
the Force.
It’s a way to underscore Anakin’s importance
to galactic events, but the prophecy is one
of the more mysterious elements of the whole
saga.
Nobody mentions where it came from or who
wrote it, or why it was so important to bring
the Force back into balance.
And given that there are Dark Side users in
The Force Awakens, it seems like a hopeless
cause anyway.
The Chosen One trope can work sometimes, but
the case can be made it should be left out
of Star Wars.
Is Boba Fett Alive?
Fans were very disappointed when bounty hunter
Boba Fett met a less-than-noble end at the
Sarlaac pit, wishing that the villain could
have stayed longer, or died with more dignity.
His lack of screen time in the original trilogy
has contributed to his rise in popularity,
and viewers want to see more of him.
The debate rages on that Boba could still
be alive, having escaped the Sarlaac.
The new Star Wars canon has yet to answer
this, with the only clue being the appearance
of Mandalorian armor in the novel Aftermath.
If a Boba spinoff movie is in the works, fans
may discover the truth.
Who Discovered the Force?
The Star Wars films present only a snippet
of the universe’s vast history, leaving
much more left to be explored.
Obi-Wan mentions that the Jedi were the guardians
of the Old Republic for over 1,000 generations,
meaning the Force had to have been discovered
a long, long time ago.
It would be an interesting story to see unfold,
since the Force is such a unique and fascinating
concept.
Learning that you can control objects with
your mind and sense people’s presences is
a monumental, life-changing event – and
it’s something that had huge ramifications
on the galaxy.
Who’s Funding the Rebels?
The Empire has plenty of resources at their
disposal to wage a war, since their reach
covers several areas of the galaxy, but what
about their opponents?
A ragtag bunch struggling to make ends meet,
the Rebels have a number of ships and supplies
they need for the conflict, and that stuff
probably doesn’t come cheap.
It’s hinted that certain sympathizing systems
like Alderaan may supply some funds, but it’s
something fans never know for sure.
Since the Rebel Alliance emerges victorious,
their financial sources are the real heroes
of the saga who never get a moment in the
spotlight.
Obi-Wan’s Tatooine Vacation
After the fall of the Jedi Order, Obi-Wan
Kenobi goes into exile on Tatooine, so he
can keep a close eye on young Luke.
But with 19 years taking place between Episodes
III and IV, it’s hard to believe that all
Obi-Wan did was baby sit.
While he probably remained low key to avoid
attention, Kenobi probably found some adventures
to be had on the desert world as he waited
for Luke to get old enough to start Jedi training.
With rumors of an Obi-Wan standalone film
refusing to go away, fans may just get to
see what he was up to before the original
movie began.
Where’s Lando?
Introduced in The Empire Strikes Back, Lando
Calrissian is a major player in the final
two installments of the original trilogy,
even helping destroy the second Death Star.
It’s odd, then, that he seems to have no
presence in the new films.
Lando does not appear in The Force Awakens
and isn’t even mentioned.
To some fans, Lando is as important to the
franchise as Luke, Han, and Leia, and with
Episode VII playing catch up, it would have
been nice to know Lando’s state.
Billy Dee Williams was not part of the recently
announced Episode 8 cast, so unless there’s
a surprise, his time in the war may be over
– without anyone knowing why.
Those are our picks for 10 unanswered Star
Wars mysteries.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones leave you confused the most?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos like this one!